muy buenas tardes mi nombre es margarita
maría gómez y soy la mamá de mi hilo y
depedro de 10 y de 8 años desde que mis
hijos estaban en viviente mi esposo y yo
siempre nos comunicamos con ellos nos
comunicamos con ellos a través de sus
movimientos de sus patadas de sus
momentos de quietud
cuando yo reaccionaba en frente a un
cuento frente a una historia que les
estábamos contando
a medida que ellos han venido creciendo
hemos establecido una relación una
relación en la que hemos aprendido a
escucharlos e interpretar todas sus
señales
los niños se siguen comunicando a través
de sus dibujos de sus momentos de
quietud de silencio también cuando se
aíslan de las demás personas
hoy quiero contarles la historia de
luisa luisa es una niña de 3 años que
regularmente iba a la casa de su abuela
a compartir por las tardes su abuela la
cuidaba luisa en alguna oportunidad le
pidió a su abuela que la acompañara
hacer una siesta su abuela le dijo que
claro se fueron para la cama y luisa le
dijo que por favor le hiciera un masaje
como se lo hacía a su papá y su abuela
con alegría le dijo claro linda
explícame cómo es el masaje que te hace
tu papá
luisa le dijo que su papá cuando estaban
acostados ponía sus manos entre sus
piernitas y comenzaba a acariciarlo
hasta que ella sintiera unas cosquillas
fue así como su abuela se dio cuenta de
que luisa estaba siendo abusada
sexualmente por su padre
cuando un niño es abusado el relato que
él nos da es espontáneo y se puede dar
una única vez y nunca puede que nunca
vuelva a repetirse
por eso los adultos tenemos que
escucharlos y especialmente creerles
siempre creerles
el abuso sexual infantil se da en
nuestra ciudad y en todo el mundo no
reconoce condición económica ni estrato
social en promedio recibimos 6 denuncias
diarias de abuso sexual infantil y
estamos seguros de que son las cifras
muy superiores y que no tenemos cómo
identificar es de su registro y lo peor
aún es que en el 86% de los casos el
victimario abusador es una persona de la
familia quiere decir eso que puede ser
el papá el abuelo el tío y también hay
algo hay mujeres abusadores
voy a contarle la historia de mónica
mónica es una de esas mujeres que
trabaja como muchas de nosotras y que
tuvo que acudir a buscar a una persona
que cuidara de su hija
ella hizo una búsqueda muy rigurosa
porque quería encontrar una persona de
toda su confianza que se hiciera cargo
de su hija fue así como encontró y
eligió una persona ya mayor que trabajó
anteriormente como religiosa
esta mujer se mostraba muy cariñosa y
afectuosa con su hija un día mónica
llegó del trabajo y se encontró a su
hija desnuda corriendo por la casa le
preguntó por qué estaba desnuda y la
niña le dijo mamá tengo calor
esta situación comenzó a hacerse
recurrente ya repetirse en diversas
ocasiones y a mónica ya no le comenzó a
gustar un dia mónica llegó de su trabajo
y encontró la pantalla del computador
encendida
mónica ingreso a la pantalla desbloqueo
el computador y se encontró con imágenes
pornográficas
cuando llegó la noche mónica se sentó
con su hija y le preguntó si su niña
estaba viendo estas imágenes ella le
explicó que es una na la sentaba al
frente del computador y cuando se
sentaba le mostraba estas imágenes y
además comenzaba a acariciar la por todo
su cuerpo
fue así como mónica se dio cuenta que
esa persona en la cual había depositado
toda su confianza estaba abusando
sexualmente de su hija
quiero explicarles que el abuso sexual
infantil no se da únicamente cuando hay
una penetración el abuso sexual infantil
se da de muchas otras formas cuando
acarician a un niño le tocan sus
genitales hay abuso sexual infantil
cuando le toman fotos o videos desnudo
hay abuso sexual infantil cuando tienen
relaciones sexuales con ella cuando le
muestran pornografía cuando le tocan los
genitales a ese niño o cuando obligan al
niño a que le toque los genitales al
adulto
también hay abuso cuando los adultos
obligamos a los niños a que les den
besos en la boca
por eso nosotros los adultos los padres
de familia cualquier ciudadano debe
saber cómo identificar cuando hay una
situación de abuso sexual infantil
cuando un niño está abusado nos habla de
muchas formas y un niño no sabe decirnos
y referir que está siendo abusado porque
él no sabe lo que le está pasando por
eso nosotros tenemos que estar atentos a
esas señales tanto físicas como
comportamental es que ellos nos dan
esas señales físicas son los padres de
familia conocemos el cuerpo también de
nuestros niños y tenemos que mirarlo
constantemente tenemos que identificar
si ellos tienen irritación o mal olor en
sus genitales si tienen fluidos también
cuando hay una enfermedad de transmisión
sexual en un menor de 14 años o un
embarazo
esa es una clara evidencia de que hay un
abuso sexual perder el control de
esfínteres también es abuso sexual
también es una señal de abuso sexual
infantil bueno y aquí vienen digamos que
las señales que nosotros como adultos
tenemos que aprender a interpretar más y
son esas señales que nos dan ellos
cuando se comunican con nosotros cuando
ellos están deprimidos cuando lloran de
manera constante cuando tienen
comportamientos sexuales que no
corresponden a su edad cuando tienen
ideas is suicidas y cuando generan
rechazo hacia una persona o hacia un
lugar específicamente también cuando
pierden el apetito y cuando bajan su
rendimiento escolar
nuestro reto es no queremos más
denuncias queremos cero abusos sexuales
y yo como mamá estoy convencida de que
lo podemos lograr como si nosotros nos
informamos y le enseñamos a nuestros
hijos a prevenir el abuso sexual
infantil si les hablamos a ellos de
manera clara y concreta de qué es lo que
le pueden hacer algunas personas
como prevenimos el abuso sexual infantil
hay varias estrategias nosotros como
padres de familia y cuidadores tenemos
que enseñarles a sus hijos a nuestros
hijos perdón cuáles son las partes de su
cuerpo cuáles son esas partes públicas y
privadas que nadie puede tocar y cuando
digo nadie es el abuelo gonzalo el tío
juan el primo pedro o la prima juanita
hay que decirlo con nombre y apellido
para que ellos sepan quiénes son esas
personas que no pueden acceder a ellos
no podemos decirles nadie porque ellos
no saben quién es nadie
tenemos que hablar del tema en casa
porque hablar del tema en casa porque
como les decía ahora en la mayoría de
los casos el abusador hace parte de la
familia y en la familia tienen que saber
que hay una persona que le enseña a los
hijos a cuidarse y que está atenta a
cualquiera de sus señales y que los
protege y los cuidas los victimarios se
aprovechan de los niños más solos y más
vulnerables esa es una estrategia que
ellos usan entonces no podemos permitir
que identifican a los niños a nuestros
niños como personitas vulnerables
a los niños debemos enseñarles el pudor
y esto es una cosa que me causó
muchísima atención también voy a
contarles una historia hay un
investigador
que estaba haciendo un estudio acerca de
que motiva a los abusadores para abusar
de un niño
esta persona quería analizar esos
comportamientos esas conductas o que los
motiva a ellos
en medio de esta investigación él llegó
un día a su casa
y se encontró con su hija de 12 años que
pasó por el frente en toalla
ese día el la vio con ojos diferentes y
entendió que un abusador puede ser
cualquier persona las personas se
erotizan fácilmente y nosotros no
podemos permitir que nuestros niños
hagan erotizar a terceras personas por
eso tenemos que enseñarles el pudor a
que no caminen desnudos por la casa por
otros lugares hay que enseñarles por el
bien de ellos que deben proteger su
cuerpo y su integridad como adultos
debemos acompañar también el uso de
internet un niño menor de 14 años no
debe tener redes sociales la ley lo
prohíbe y los adultos debemos supervisar
ese uso de las herramientas y también
explicarles a ellos claramente que hay
personas que los buscan a ellos a través
de las redes sociales y que quieren
hacerles daño explicarles clara y
concretamente
en algunos hogares y familias es posible
que se den condiciones de hacinamiento
crítico que debemos procurar que los
adultos duerman con adultos los niños
con niños y los adolescentes tampoco
deben dormir con niños porque cada vez
más también adolescentes abusadores
como adultos cabemos también en ese
error de decirles secretos a nuestros
niños las cosas buenas no hay porqué
ocultarlas y los secretos son la
estrategia que utilizan los abusadores
para acceder a los niños entonces hay
que decirles que ellos no deben
guardarle ningún secreto a nadie
entonces no debemos utilizar esta
estrategia con ellos
la historia de luisa y de mónica son
reales ellas ya están pasando por un
proceso que procure remediar esa
condición de vida el abuso sexual
infantil genera huellas y secuelas
irreparables en el desarrollo
neurológico de un niño y también en el
relacionamiento de esa persona cuando
sea adulto a nivel psicológico a nivel
social a nivel emocional por eso hoy yo
quiero ser diciéndoles que ustedes
tienen la oportunidad de cambiar la
realidad de los niños que tenemos a
nuestro alrededor
hablen con sus familias hablen al
interior de sus hogares acerca de este
tema vuélvase replicadores de esta
información y estoy segura que así
nosotros podremos lograr cumplir y
materializar los sueños de nuestros
niños eso es lo que tenemos que hacer
como sociedad muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]